nehmen sie einfach die besten
doch geht ihnen präsentiert von fluor
punkt ch
[Musik]
es war einmal ein mann den alle vier abi
kari nannten
[Musik]
dieser mann wanderte in die karibik aus
wo er all sein geld verloren
[Musik]
dafür fand vier abi carport die liebe
und er hatte vier söhne die alle
irgendwann den umgekehrten weg des
vaters machten von der dominikanischen
republik in die schweiz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in diesem drama geht es um werden und
vergehen
zum träumen und scheitern und flüchten
und standhalten
[Musik]
damit schluss machen wir diese anderes
das ist die unendliche geschichte einer
familie und ihrer suche nach dem glück
irgendwo zwischen hier und dort
[Musik]
carlos feierabend hat 17 jahre lang also
die hälfte seines lebens am
vierwaldstättersee sozusagen im herzen
der schweiz gelebt geliebt und
gearbeitet
ich habe eigentlich gut da so schlecht
habe ich nicht aber ich
bin ich nicht ganz zufrieden
ich suche meinen glücken die
dominikanische republik gewesen
mit 17 jahren ist carlos im kanton uri
angekommen voller träume und hoffnungen
jetzt mit 34 scheint die schwerkraft des
lebens den schweizer aus der karibik ein
wenig ausgerichtet zu haben
carlos und all seine brüder wohnen heute
in der heimat ihres vaters
[Musik]
sie haben hier arbeit und freunde
gefunden
[Musik]
völlig neuen wasch mache
und ja auch liebe in diesem fall
zusammen ihrer ragati 27 derzeit
arbeitslos
und trotzdem fehlt etwas
was ist das deshalb habe ich angefangen
von fünf jahre zu denken ob sie
zurückkehren soll oder nicht und
ich gehe zurück
[Musik]
ein paar jahre bevor er samira traf
schien sein glück bereits perfekt zu
sein er wurde vater
ich sehe mein kind eigentlich sehr
selten und
mein verhältnis mit dem mond der von
meines sohnes nicht gerade so wird es
gibt ja wenn wie bei mehrere fonds ein
anderer geht man habe nach dem 1
auch andere
und jetzt sind fünf jahre wo wir sind
wenn die kommen
wir würden uns nicht gut verstehen und
das dass ich
glücklich bin ich immer noch aber das
machen wir ein wenig
traurig dazu
es hatte so schön angefangen
2014 im kantonsspital uri ich bin eher
so wie ein traum immer noch seite zeit
ja das erste mal über nicht da gekommen
wären sie hat solche menschen
ja
dann auch nicht so richtig erfahren
aber das schön
meine finger
schon bald nach diesen aufnahmen trennte
sich das paar und seither ist es kurz
gesagt schwierig
und ich kann ich nicht sehen das tut
noch mal wenn ich weit kommen kann kann
ich mir anders dann gehören und ich weiß
mein sohn wird von mir suchen ich bete
dass weiß nicht ich
habe im moment
ich finde
ich habe keinen platz
letzte mal mitgenommen
jetzt will carlos also auswandern und
samira seine neue liebe möchte ihn nach
rennjury war dorthin wo er aufgewachsen
ist begleiten
[Musik]
carlos packt alles was ihm wichtig ist
zusammen seine zeit in der schweiz geht
zu ende er will in der karibik ganz neu
anfangen
auf der farm seines vaters
mein vater gekannt habe wenn ich würde
für zählen also wenn er wusste was sich
da ein löwe oder wenn das ganze mit
meiner situation besser gesagt
er wurde ja auch saga ich gott komme ich
zurück in die berge der dominikanischen
republik
[Musik]
hierher zog es in den 80er jahren einige
schweizer auswanderer die tore in ein
kleines kaff namens runkeeper in eine
landschaft die manchmal ein bisschen an
die schweiz
[Musik]
dort traf ich carl feierabend zum ersten
mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
carlos heißt hier früher kali kommt das
rotkreuz karl feierabend der in seinem
ersten leben für alle vier a big kammer
17 jahre lang war er schnaps mit eigener
bringen gern gesehen auf allen höfen
[Musik]
dann
1982 begann sein zweites leben charakter
haben gut in einem container und
verschickte ihn hierher in die tropen
[Musik]
pharma wollte er werden groß fahren
dass er hier nur gerade ein paar gänse
statt einer rinderherde vor sich her
treiben würde hatte sich damals zu hause
in rotkreuz nicht träumen lassen 17
jahre lang hatte er gespannt über 200000
franken immerhin aus startkapital in der
frage
[Gelächter]
sondern
kann ich wie sonne und
da
von den wenig
konsumiert
und so hatte es begonnen kari schloss
sich einer gruppe land interessenten an
und flog auf die karibikinsel auf
vermittlung der schweizerisch
dominikanische maklergruppe ini
besichtigte kari einige fahnen und
entschloss sich schließlich zusammen mit
fischer hans aus dem toggenburg zum kauf
einer farm von 93 hektar
66 davon gehörten kari in einem
achteckigen besuchsprogramm waren sie
durchs land geschleust worden für nur 50
rappen pro tag könne man hier taglöhner
anstellen wurde versprochen und bereits
am 8 tage hieß es vertragsabschlüsse in
unseren büros nachmittags frei die
groupie nie versprach bei der
bewirtschaftung behilflich zu sein und
schloss mit kari einen vertrag ab die
marke kauften dünger und saatgut
versprachen die ernte zu verkaufen und
rechneten die schönen gewinne aus die
dazu machen sein die bohnen wuchsen zwar
durchaus den gewinnen wurde nichts kari
wahl auf falsche berechnungen
hereingefallen sind sieht eine derart
gläubig sie
im nachhinein reicher sind lisicki
nach anderthalb jahren war es pleite
kari verlost ein ganzes land für das er
über 200000 franken hingeblättert hatte
ein lebenstraum in trümmern
wieso sind sie der gleichen schweiz
zurückgegangen
die schweiz nehme mika hat alles was ich
kann nicht so gut mit und konnten
im laufe der zeit sind noch weitere
gründe dazu gekommen eine heißt marina
und eine kalus
[Gelächter]
aus dem baby von damals ist ein mann
geworden einer der vor sieben jahren
selbst vater wurde
sagte sie schade dass ich so weit weg
vor allem kann mich nicht besuchen
kommen wenn er das will
aber wir haben abgemacht dass er kommt
mit kompressor handeln der karibik eines
tages mit dem muttersein
schon morgen fliegen sie zusammen in die
dominikanische republik
[Musik]
carlos wandert definitiv aus und samira
will sich auf dieser reise klar darüber
werden ob sie sich ein leben in der
karibik wirklich vorstellen kann
ich sage 23
dies fertig ein geweckt
[Musik]
carlos ist in seiner zeit in der schweiz
zum begeisterten schrebergärtner
geworden
[Musik]
seine paar quadratmeter land außerhalb
von früheren haben ihm in den
vergangenen jahren über manche dunkle
stunden hinweg geholfen
in der schweiz zu kursen mit der heute
und wir sind sehr betroffen und was
karriere genommen und es war für uns
also für mich und meine brötchen
und zeitig sagen wir mit mir zusammen
ist auch noch und heute ist der letzte
tag im garten ja
egal wie traurig aber
an seinem letzten abend in der schweiz
hat carlos seine brüder verwandte und
freunde zu einem abschiedsfest
eingeladen
onkel und tante lisbeth sind gekommen
und sah mir us mutter angela die sich
nur schwer mit dem gedanken anfreunden
kann dass ihre tochter vielleicht
auswandert
ich habe ich den boden verloren und ist
ich war jetzt nicht erfüllt sie dass sie
sofort andere tut aber zusätzlich hat
das alles mit den experten sogar das
sieht manchmal kollegen
im inneren hofft man natürlich dass
beide zu klemmen
carlos entscheidung die schweiz zu
verlassen macht den einen sorgen
andere scheinen ihn fast ein wenig um
seinen mut zu beneiden
so etwas ami der jüngste der feierabend
brüder
waren vorher schon
mal
an vater und die
halle sache denn die früchte darf ist
eine sache
bp den zweitgeborenen der hier ebenfalls
einen schrebergarten gemietet hat klagen
indes keine auswanderungs gelüste
momentan ich habe so viele weitere
bildung gemacht und da lässt und meine
frau geht sicher nicht mit das ist die
grosse teil und ich habe jetzt ein kind
im monat und ich glaube ich glaube in
der wenige ich will das einfach da
aufwächst und eine richtige ausbildung
machen
[Musik]
nach fast 40 jahren wiederholt sich die
geschichte der feierabend in gewisser
weise wie einst kari bricht nun wieder
ein feierabend in richtung truppen auf
[Musik]
wir laden stehen jeder
scalzo wm hatte ich sowieso überlagern
oder sie hand sichern gratis wohnen es
ist eigentlich vor dem hard nicht das
problem ferner sind immer kaffee und
hallen das land eigentlich nur
eigentlich
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen am flughafen zürich
nun müssen sie abschied nehmen
vom patenkind von
der schwiegermutter
von den brüdern
und von den schwestern
es wurden
ja
ich fühle mich nicht mal nervös haben
gefühl ich kann man in die ferien
realisierte das noch nicht manche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
doch längere zeit und man weiß nicht wie
es weitergeht aber ich freue mich
erzählen mit dem die reist machen
[Musik]
gut 15 jahre nach seiner auswanderung
haben wir den viera biccari ein zweites
mal besucht
denn die frage stellte sich warum kehrt
einer wie er pleite wie er war nicht
einfach in die schweiz zurück unter das
dach des sozialstaates es war nicht
schwierig ihn wiederzufinden
in rancho arriba dem kleinen dorf im
café gebiet wo er genau lebt sieht man
von weitem
[Musik]
die
banken fürchten
und geschirr sieben junge tänzer
wahrscheinlich habe ich noch gespielt
naja
ich erinner sie
trotz pleite und pech ist calida
geblieben und auf anhieb käme keiner auf
die idee dass es sich hier um einen
ausländer handeln karl lebt wie ein
einheimischer campino eine mit schweizer
fahne allerdings
harry hat sich mit ein paar tausend
franken die ihm nach seiner pleite von
damals übrig geblieben waren drei hektar
und lernt in der gleichen gegend gekauft
hier lebt er seit elf jahren aus
kleinbauer und irgendwie wundert er sich
noch heute darüber wie er hierher
geraten ist
ich schneide dir eine dem abriss wo die
dominikanische republik ist
angeblich kein versand oder minka
aber nico ist in santo domingo
dominikanische republik
[Musik]
und am abend trennten sie von santo
domingo
[Musik]
ab und zu zieht des kali zurück wie eine
große schöne farben die ihm einmal
gehört hatte und die er nach nur
anderthalb jahren verloren hatte weil
ihm das geld ausgegangen war
[Musik]
und davon
hier jeder
[Musik]
226.000 franken charis ganze ersparnisse
sind hier verläuft nach caris pleite
unter der vorbesitzer das land ein
zweites mal verkaufen aber karl der am
anfang praktisch kein spanisch sprach
klickte das alles auch erst nach und
nach mit
[Musik]
inzwischen hat der vier söhne carl
fredricksen
und sap addon vier schweizer jubeln habe
zufrieden so viel gotthelf gibt es nur
noch in der karibik
[Musik]
großes glück in einer bescheidenen hütte
alles selber gebaut und kali zwei zimmer
oder eine küche
[Musik]
im schlafzimmer wachen nebst hiesigen
heiligen auch schweizer ikonen über die
hälfe des karibischen
sich den platz
auf drei hektar die einmal wiese waren
ist eine veritable plantage entstanden
mit zwölf sorten bananen orangen
mandarinen pensions- früchten kiwis und
kaffee
der bereich software
[Musik]
richtig
gut
[Musik]
kaffee ist ein unsicheres geschäft kari
lebt mehr schlecht als recht von seinem
kleinen anwesen am café verdiente er
wenn's hochkommt 1000 bis 2000 franken
im jahr überlebt hat weil es eine
schweiß anlage aus der schweiz
mitgebracht hatte er fliegt alles was
ihm die nachbarn bringen so kommt er auf
ein monatseinkommen von umgerechnet
250 bis 300 franken
er ist so ein fleißiger mensch
hat er kümmert sich um die kinder er ist
immer hier ist sehr häuslich
die aus trinkt nicht und nicht auf der
straße rum
ein guter
ehrlich dieser richtige bahn
es schneidet ihn nie ab
dieser bat
das gefällt mir nicht
so viel haare im gesicht und
gestohlen
und betrogen
erfahren
als er von
dem verloren
total unglücklich nicht los
ich weiß beteiligt sich an der dritten
konferenz der europäischen konvention
gegen den nächsten beiden wochen
aus dem innerschweizer schnapsbrenner
ist ein karibischer campino geworden
der einzige allerdings der schweizer
radio international hörte so lange es
dieses noch da
[Musik]
die noch
heute ist von paris bescheidenem heim in
den bergen der dominikanischen republik
nur noch eine ruine übrig
eine ruine voller erinnerungen
[Musik]
so
2 pol
jetzt mein vater café gewaschen
und jetzt haben wir nicht so viel kaffee
und ich dachte jetzt wenn wir das
wegnehmen das frische spuren
und nachher machen wir sowieso eine
us-tochter
ja darum haben wir zusammen geschlagen
paris kleine farm ist völlig
heruntergekommen ehrlich gesagt sie
gleicht inzwischen einer müllhalde
[Musik]
bevor daran zu denken ist sich hier
wohnlich einzurichten müssen carlos und
seine partnerin samira zuerst einmal
versuchen ein wenig ordnung ins chaos zu
bringen
es könnte wirklich schlimm ausgesehen
und so ist es halt leider
mitteilte zieht investieren und ortet
aber ich denke wenn mir das wirklich
immer wieder
kommt es gut
für carlos ist es ein nachhausekommen in
ratgeber
für samira ein kulturschock
alle paar minuten ein neuer
spontanbesucher der auf einen schwanz
vorbeikommt
ok ja ich musste sagen wir schon
vielfach ich
sage
einfach blöd vor will man halt einfach
nun aber zur stadt und irgendwie ihr
wollten wir auch mit den rettern
das geht einfach nicht und man versteht
nicht
was macht eine ausgeburt wenn man das
immer
noch gehört will man strengt sich an zum
irgend ein bisschen nichts versteht
aber
es wird nur 8 und das ist das schon
macht eine social media
das muss sie
ist nicht so einfach das recht die
region und da reden die leute ziemlich
viel dass sie mir am tag da und da
kommen sicher 20 leute immer wieder eine
und dann ganze hat da eine halbe stunde
und ja ich glaube dass für sie ist
einfach ist und
ich hoffe
ja
mal was kommt
die kleine farm der feier abends liegt
ein bisschen außerhalb von taliban einem
verschlafenen kleinen kaff gute zwei
autostunden von santo domingo entfernt
also ziemlich weit weg vom schuss
besucher aus europa verirren sich kaum
je hierher
[Musik]
bis die farm bewohnbar ist haben sich
tadellos untermieter bei marina carlos
mutter einquartiert
[Musik]
sie lebt hier mit ihrem partner manolo
und freut sich ihren sohn der sein
halbes leben in der schweiz war wieder
bei sich zu haben
ich bin überglücklich ich habe mir immer
gedacht dass einer meiner söhne zurück
kommen könnte
ich wollte ein haus wie dieses aber die
finger haben wir behalten für den fall
dass er zurückkommt
marina umsorgt das junge paar sie und
sie haben ein dach über der
privatsphäre gibt es hier allerdings
kaum
[Musik]
ja ich fühle mich unwohl will ich habe
meine mutter in der nähe
und die kann froh sein dass sie kann das
schlafen im moment ist sie auf dem
fahrer alles fertig ist
es gibt selber mir nicht gefällt das wo
ich nicht so bekommen aber das sind
kleine sachen
das ist in ordnung so also es muss sagen
wie mich ist eigentlich mit also sich
klar
dass ungarn
aber ich bin sehr herzlich empfangen
worden
für die monate und auf jedem kind und
für die verwandten treffen
sich alle ganz lieb und kann aus ich
mache mich sehr gern und
sei dankbar dass sie der stasi und dass
sie das zimmer parat gemacht hat
uns herzlich
wir haben dich mit uns
ich will dass du da bleibst mir sie ist
eben das beste machen
[Musik]
catala master sollte problem die presse
das
ist meine position und
bekommen keine boni
ich bin froh dass amira wiemer ich
und ich bin auch von asyl
gewähren wenn sie nicht glücklich werden
und dank
[Musik]
[Applaus]
carlos möchte samira ein leben in der
dominikanischen republik schmackhaft
machen unter anderem mit den exotischen
früchten die hier direkt vor der
haustüre wachsen
ja
orange money sowie die aktionäre
alle gesetze wurden nicht
zurückgeschnitten
die sind einfach nur aufgewachsen
es gibt viel arbeit
damit machen
oder sind die sterne frucht jetzt hat ja
aus der ruine des hauses in dem carlos
aufgewachsen ist möchten die beiden
anheim machen für ihre gemeinsame
zukunft
das seinen weg
dass der weg schlagen das ist so bekannt
dass der ganzen
breite
noch
233 noch da kommt dem boden noch nachher
jeden
tag nicht so ein 10
444 personen gehabt das habe ich nicht
gut geordnet erinnerungen an eine zeit
in der die feierabend buben noch ihre
zukunft träumten wasser gesetzt
ja ich wollte eigentlich herr finden war
er findet und das hat mir im weg war
also in der schule war weil ich nie
richtig gut aber
ich habe immer das experiment gemacht in
der weltstadt von vater und
ja das ist einfach träume sind träumen
das bleibt immer noch lachte sieht am
schluss machen wir etwas anderes
hier sind carlos und seine brüder zur
schule gegangen ohne danach wirkliche
perspektive zu haben
die arbeitslosigkeit beträgt mehr als 50
prozent und jeder der hier noch bei
trost ist sagt sich nichts wie weg in
ein anderes land in die usa nach spanien
oder eben in die schweiz
da liegt der älteste sohn von karl wird
hilfe von allen beneidet er hat einen
schweizer pass er kann gehen
und so kam es denn das am 4 august 2005
alito feierabend in der schweiz eintraf
erwartet von seiner tante lisbeth und
jede menge
deutsch kann khalid fast gar nicht mit
seinem vater hat er immer spanisch
geredet erste verständigung versuche
die st
so macht der sohn des kali den
umgekehrten weg wie sein vater er will
hier arbeiten geld verdienen dass er
seinen vater in die karibik schicken
kann und der will in der schweiz das
werden was bisher mühsam pass verspricht
ein richtiger schweizer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein weiteres jahr ist ins land gegangen
auf dem weg ins richtige schweizer turm
ist gallito gerade dabei auch den
schweizerischen führerausweis zu
erwerben fast und im hippie monte carlo
wohnt jetzt in früheren im herzen der
schweiz sozusagen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er lebt bei seiner tante lisbeth der
schwester seines vaters und ihrem mann
set und man hat ihn hier offensichtlich
gern
[Musik]
man kann ihn brauchen den sauberen
carlito ein braves schweizer buch der
seinen verwandten sogar den kaffee
bringt
da sitzt ein zimmer das ist mein ding
wie lebst du
gut
bist du bist du aber
manchmal ist es in schwer freunde zu
finden und in der schweiz alles für mich
schon jetzt haben sich nicht wenig
hayek ein ähnliches oder
weiß nicht wen ich ja vielleicht täte
mir nicht aber
ja finde ich ja warum also auch zugeben
dass
ich
das kann nicht geredet aber
ich meine es gefällt dir
gefällt mir genug was gefragt die dann
habe ich in der schweiz
also
viele kreischende frauen
ja
wohl nicht fehl wenig weil er ein
bisschen einsam ist hatte sich 24 einige
freunde angeschafft -
ich kann nicht ein hundehalter darf eine
rate also wollte ich ein affe alles muss
in afrika kaufen
hier schon einen rate und gefällt mir
was eigentlich der grund warum du in die
schweiz kommen wird ist also
mein vater half seinem vater hilft ja um
eine familie aus geld verdienen und da
gefordert ja okay das ja bis jetzt zwar
nicht aber vielleicht kommt ja und wie
willst du held von einfach geld schicken
oder land kann auch verwirrte was also
ich wollte
eben etwas
immer wollte
also eine aussender also er hat schon
eine oder aber
ich wollte an der haustür der familie
und meine produkte wollten in der
universität in seoul und ja ich wollte
bezahlen für alle
dass das viele geld das er verdienen
möchte in der schweiz nicht auf der
straße liegt musste gallito schnell
lernen jetzt arbeitet er für 20 franken
in der stunde in der fenster fabrik
bündner in erstfeld wo man grundsätzlich
des lobes voll ist über ihn er macht
hier die erfahrungen eines ganz
gewöhnlichen immigranten einfache arbeit
statt plötzlichen reichtums und er hat
ein dilemma er ist zwar ein schweizer
mit pass aber irgendwie halten alle für
irgendetwas anderes
ist das hier anders aussehen der karibik
welchen andere was ist der unterschied
sei alles ganz perfekt machen
das kann nicht sein
milito ist in einer schweiz geraten von
denen keine ahnung hatte eine moderne
durch organisierte gesellschaft weit und
breit kein pferdefuhrwerk
du bist das land so wie du gedacht hast
es nicht so ganz andere was hast du
gedacht dass sein land ja wie man ein
fahrrad immer erzählt eine wand mit
krieg
viele bauern so wenn ich bin gekommen
ist jonas
[Applaus]
nein nein mach mal so und
denkst du dass deine zukunft ist ja ich
denke schon so
was ist mein größter wunsch
als ein kulturwandel
eine schöne haus wo ich kann meine
familie haben auch an der
eine frau in dem auch viele kollegen ein
wesentlicher schritt in der
verschweißung des schweizers carlito ist
natürlich die sprache
einmal pro woche besuchte den
deutschunterricht in autor also
hierherkam sprache wie gesagt noch kein
wort und wenn das gegenüber stimmt man
sieht es gleich lernt es sich leichter
[Applaus]
kurz darauf mit carlito in die feuerwehr
aufgenommen
und das sollten auch die letzten zweifel
an seinem schweizer team zum schweigen
bringen
[Musik]
nach anderthalb jahren erstmals wieder
zurück in der dominikanischen republik
zusammen mit seiner tante lisbeth und
ihrem mann selbst zu besuch beim vater
und bei den brüdern
[Musik]
piccard ist sich äußerlich nicht groß
verändert doch vieles läuft nicht so wie
er sich erträumt hatte geld wird immer
mehr zur mangelware
einfach gesagt kari ist nun wirklich am
vorabend jetzt haben wir gerade
wenn man sie sehen durch weiter wenn ich
kein tor
ja
und jetzt sensibler schweiz
verteilt
traf jan januar noch einmal antreten
will
kann hier werden und die plant sich ein
langsames aber für eine dritte nino vor
dem kraut juni gesetzt
und wir trauern grausam
schwierige probleme finanziell
versteckte und der bananen staaten hat
carlos eine improvisierte
schnapsbrennerei aufgebaut ihr bringt
der verschiedene sorten exotischer
schnäpse schwarz natürlich
[Musik]
der trainer von fahrern die schnäpse
haben 62 prozent alkohol und schmecken
am besten als kaffee schnaps mit tropen
und
das ich habe wurde ich wie
sehen ihre gruppe
der atome
aus dem waschkessel ist eine
funktionstüchtige busch destillerie
geworden
carlito ist für seine brüder so etwas
wie ein vorbild er hat sich einen
computer angeschafft und zeigte ihnen
bilder aus der fernen heimat schweiz er
ist ihr wegbereiter in die bessere
zukunft
denn auch sami freddy und pepe träumen
nur davon dorthin zu ziehen wo milch und
honig fließt also in die schweiz lieber
heute als morgen
[Musik]
macht mit seinem buben den ganzen
haushalt denn seine ehefrau marina ist
wieder einmal weg dieses mal ist sind
spanien wo sie als putzfrau arbeitet um
das einkommen der familie aufzubessern
eine zeit lang war sie in miami denn wir
wollen es nicht verschweigen auch das
eheglück der feierabend ist nicht mehr
so wie einst im
[Gelächter]
mit dem selbst gebackenem brot bananen
schnaps und käse aus der schweiz fühlt
man sich ein bisschen wie vor bis heute
eine idylle auf zeit die frau ist
auswärts und auch die kinder wollen so
bald wie möglich weg
sonst hatte cani bei solchen
gelegenheiten gerne das lied auf meiner
ranch bin ich könig gesungen doch heute
stand in der sinn nach etwas traurigen
[Musik]
ja ja wir gleich die gtz
ferrari und
1.1 endlich weg wie sie bei weniger
kreis und comedia als
tiefstapler der petrus
damaseb
bestimmt und ein
[Musik]
am späteren abend ging es ganz und gar
nicht mehr gut er musste in das fast
drei stunden entfernte spital gebracht
werden es wurde in schlechter auf den
holprigen straßen er konnte kaum mehr
atmen aber es tat ihm weh ein
wiedersehen im netz
alles deutet darauf hin dass kali einen
kleineren herzinfarkt gehabt hatte und
als mich so drückt auf der großen und
der druck auf der brust
noch bevor die vaio p
[Musik]
niemand hätte es gedacht nach einem tag
im spital hatte kari abends um halb elf
einen zweiten herzinfarkt der sofort
tödlich war
[Musik]
das habe dürfen am anteil an seinem
schicksal
25 jahre sind wir nun nachbarn gewesen
aber ich kann nichts schlechtes über ihn
sagen nur gutes nur das
[Musik]
ja
ganz komische fans
[Musik]
doch die starke fahrt
mit dem gare hängt
ein toter tut
das
die nächsten
knapp steuerlich sympathisch dass sie da
auch mit
prof
peter buck zeit
auf meiner ranch bin ich
[Musik]
trete
das land vor ihm sieht also da nur
verdammt denn sich
herausgeholt der hänger dollar
aus der traum
[Musik]
da los wie war das jetzt ohne den vater
ich werde
sehen wie schwierig ja
mit uns
gemacht
diese nacht war nicht
jungs das war ganz komisch gelaufen
inwieweit es nicht mehr
aus dem du jetzt die rolle des vaters
seine eignung ja
ich will doch so
ich habe mich immer eine brise
aber was ist dann wenn die schweiz
bietet ja ich komme wieder
im dezember
ja
albern ist
in einem vorort von barcelona treffe ich
marina wieder die witwe von kari
arbeitet viel als hausangestellte weil
sie kein flugticket und kein geld hatte
konnte sie auch nicht zurück fliegen aus
dem mann stahl
[Applaus]
wie war das als sie hörte dass er
gestorben ist
es war sehr hart
ein harter schlag ich hätte nie so etwas
gedacht
ich dachte wenn ich dorthin zurückkehre
werde ich ihn antreffen
wie immer
nie hätte ich gedacht dass mich ein
solches schicksal trifft
über seinen tod hinaus hat calli für die
seinen gesorgt weil sein bruder in der
schweiz immer brav die ahv einbezahlt
hatte wird marina eine schweizerische
witwenrente bekommen und die kinder eine
waisenrente solange sie in ausbildung
sind
[Musik]
so endet die geschichte vom
schnapsbrenner kari sowie alle
geschichten von menschen irgendwann
enden und sie setzt sich gleichzeitig
fort wie sich alle geschichten von
menschen fortsetzen durch die kinder und
kindeskinder nämlich die noch lange
erzählen werden von kari der aus dem
fernen landen ausgerechnet hierher kam
wodurch alle anderen nichts wie weg
wollen
[Musik]
jetzt wird carlos die geschichte der
familie feierabend in rand sharivar
weiterschreiben
seinen neuanfang finanziert er sich mit
pensionskassengeld aus der schweiz
aber wenn er wirklich erleben will muss
er wege suchen um nicht nur geld zu
brauchen sondern auch zu verdienen
seine freien kaffee so einfach
einfach gemacht alles
rasend setzen schöne platz machen
das braucht zeit viel zeit
[Applaus]
daneben möchte er als handwerker
arbeiten und einfach wieder glücklich
sein so wie früher als
kind hatten wir da müssen der reich
gewesen also nicht mit geld andere
sachen
so viel frucht mir in der so viel zum
spieler einfach ich bin zurück wir sind
eben in wald gewesen dies mache es ist
zwar schwere kindheit muss ja seine
sehr schön
wenn das ganze freiheit in den farmen
mit viel frucht und sicherten aber nicht
mehr das gleiche wir frieren aber das
sicherlich ein für den kind und
viele andere sachen ist sicher präsident
ich weiß zum beispiel
sicherheit
wenn ein kind weiter bisher richtig
lernen es sicher besser und ich weiß
selbst
dass ich so das leben tatsächlich so
bedauerlich es
also mir gefällt das lager ist
aber nicht alle kinder holender seinem
beschluss
und auch nicht alle frauen
[Musik]
obwohl carlos sie rührend umsorgt und
ihr jeden wunsch von den augen abzulesen
versucht ist samira bedrückt
denn sie vermisst ihre mutter und ihre
schwester
samira hat heimweh aber wieder mal
keinen empfang
eine halbtags schnitt kommt der familie
und ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass
sie sich alex ashley sorge macht und
[Musik]
was
nicht so einfach gerade im moment ist
einfach in ruhe daten also
immer den gedanken
und ja man macht sich einfach immer
sorgen standen die gingen mir und er
vermisst sie denn irgendwie
daneben macht er auch zu schaffen dass
man hier nie für sich sein kann carlos
hat dauernd besuch das soll er ändern
ihre türen sollen öfter zu bleiben
[Musik]
mehr das machen wir verlieren auch viele
freunde weil mir alles so zu machen
notizen kommentar sagt ja alles zu die
hat kein interesse und dann kommen extra
nicht mehr und wir werden morgen auch
nicht mehr und dann kommen die ja gar
nicht mehr dass die kultur soll ja wir
sind offen bisher hinter der türe ganz
einfach alleine spazieren rufen wenn man
so meine ich und wenn dann sind
jemand gibt
ein lichtblick für samira sie hat wieder
empfangen
hallo
ich
so
die 20 20
stick
bringt
samir us zeit in rancho arriba geht nach
gut fünf wochen zu ende sie fliegt bald
zurück in die schweiz und muss sich
entscheiden wo sie künftig leben will in
der karibik oder in flüelen und
wie es mit ihr und carlos weitergeht
stell mir einfach viel vor mit ihm also
wirklich zukunft und dort für ihn nicht
möglich in der schweiz muss ich dann
wirklich
in mich entscheiden ob ist und es wird
so oder so schwer
entweder meine familie zurück la oder
dann in der zurück in
ein fach
natürlich und sie sich entschieden
zurückzuweisen
ja er wird leider so sein muss ich
weiter alleine machen ja und wenn sie
nochmal die schweiz gehört nun wieder
zurück kommt zu mir dass wir das würde
sicher ich würde mich sehr freuen
kurz gesagt es geht jetzt um die frage
ob diese liebe eine zukunft hat
[Musik]
nach dem tod des vaters schien klar dass
die zukunft der feierabends in der
schweiz liegt darum holt carlos bald
seinen jüngsten bruder semi zu sich
er soll in der schweiz zur schule gehen
und später eine berufslehre machen
[Musik]
freunde
nach maria b
so nehmen die kinder den gleichen weg
mit der vater nun umgekehrt und so setzt
sich das prinzip von leben und sterben
und kommen und gehen durch noch lange
nicht feierabend
ein jahr später stehen die feierabend
brüder wieder am flughafen
samy und gallito warten zusammen auf die
mutter marina
smi geht diese lange zeit der einsamkeit
zu ende
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ist ja
mit marina kommt freddy der dritte der
söhne von kari jetzt ist nur noch pepe
in der karibik doch auch er wird bald
hier sein das liegt wie wir nun gemerkt
haben sozusagen in der logik dieser
geschichte
wie geht es dir marina ich bin so
glücklich
jetzt habe ich schon mal ein trio hier
marina ist fest entschlossen hier in der
schweiz ein neues leben zu beginnen
in vita schwanden im schächental dort wo
im winter drei monate lang die sonne
scheint hat rallye tor für die ganze
familie eine wohnung gemietet eine
günstige weit ab vom schuss
[Musik]
fünfeinhalb zimmer noch etwas
provisorisch eingerichtet aber immerhin
ein neues zuhause für die familie
[Musik]
wir schauen wir ein wenig fernsehen sagt
marina obwohl sie die tagesschau noch
nicht wirklich versteht
man hier ist stolz und zeigt mir das
zimmer von carlito dass sie
ausgesprochen romantisch findet
[Gelächter]
nein einen solchen kühlschrank hatte
marina die leidenschaftliche köchin noch
nie
[Musik]
die einrichtung bringt die familie und
den rahmen dieser finanziellen kräfte
ihre einkünfte aus witten rente und
carlitos lohn liegen um die 4000 franken
pro monat aber es ist teuer in der
schweiz und die jungen sind den
elektronischen verführungen ziemlich
ausgeliefert mit schweizer franken zu
rechnen das müssen sie erst noch lernen
suchst du eigentlich arbeit hier ja ich
will etwas arbeiten
ich frage nicht was mir gefällt ich
suche irgendetwas
ich möchte nicht reich werden oder so
etwas ich möchte nur etwas zum leben
haben und
ich möchte alles was möglich ist für
mich und noch etwas mehr damit ich für
die anderen meiner familie sorgen kann
das ist frei das zimmer
und hier haben wir alle trophäen von
kari seine medaillen kristalle
du siehst du wie ein museum ja genau
und hier ist noch seine uhr
läuft immer noch
[Musik]
kari ist in der wohnung nicht präsent
die bilder an der wand machen die
familiengeschichte zur legende doch wir
wissen war es in dieser ehe nicht nur
eitel sonnenschein wie
es denn so gewesen sein mit kari wollen
wir und martina wissen
auf der einen seite war es gut aber auf
der anderen also nein
eines muss ich sagen er war fleißig und
der barcode zu den kindern da fehlte
nichts aber es fehlte etwas anderes mir
fehlte etwas ich kann so groß und ich
bin doch das wichtigste aber lassen wir
das vor der kamera
in altdorf im hotel höflich hat marina
dank der guten beziehungen ihre
schweizer verwandten eine stelle als
putzfrau gefunden
es zeigt sich allerdings baut das marina
nicht glücklich wird in der schweiz ihr
fehlt hier die soziale wärme der karibik
und darum zieht es sie schon nach zwei
jahren wieder zu
auch carlos bleibt die sehnsucht nach
seiner alten heimat mal mehr mal weniger
in der träumt immer noch den gleichen
traum den traum vom kleinen haus in
rancho lieber
in der
die kirche die wc und
nachhaltig
zu melden
wo willst du diese ausbeutung der haube
haus wo zb 19 fragen mich nach so oder
so ereignete
das wäre ungefähr
noch nicht fertig also ich muss noch
beispiel chance darauf machen
plötzlich saß
dort willst du leben ja ich meine
zukunft der
inzwischen ist carlos seinem traum einen
großen schritt näher gekommen
auf der feierabend gibt es wohl schon
bald einen neuen könig
[Musik]
er hat einen künstlichen teich angelegt
und einen unterstand für fahrzeuge
gebaut
außerdem einen kleinen schuppen für die
werkzeuge
ein paar monate nach seiner ankunft in
rancho arbeitet er gerade am dach seines
traumhauses
und ich habe jeden
außer
mit heute batterie sonntag habe ich
nicht arbeiten
natürlich habe ich jeden tag arbeit
immer bis gemacht
mit dem holz es gibt dafür 100 tor ist
noch nicht fertiges fällt noch sehr viel
es gibt es da stube es gibt fast immer
gibt es nach zwei zimmer das dach des
kübels immer wie man sagen ich weiß
und
ja es gibt das fenster von dahinten auch
gibt es noch eine andere border
das ist nur noch nach um das was jet
drauf sachen stabilität gibt
und da gibt es ja wahnsinnig gerne auf
sich nimmt man nicht aber es langt im
moment
dann ist die schlacht
ziemlich gut
mit
eine andere holz über die sich viel
besser geworden das hartholz das ich
essen ist einfach
das ist sehr wenig also mit fichten
tannen erwähnen ich weiß wäre vielleicht
ein bekannter drehte carlos allerdings
olga luxus holz an und versprachen ihm
damit an dach zu bauen
was man
besser wenn das nicht hätte als in kanus
das holz abgekauft hatte machte sich der
bekannte aus dem staub nun muss carlos
sein dach selber bauen ja jetzt muss ich
alles so
improvisieren vorhand fehler machen es
braucht sehr viel fehlt sieht derweil
ich bringe das
johannes schluss zieht dass wir gut aus
in der schweiz hat carlos eine an lehre
als schreiner gemacht und immer auf dem
beruf gearbeitet
darum liegt ihm der umgang mit holz
er hat sich sogar ein kleines baumhaus
gebaut
ein liebevoll eingerichtete rückzugsort
für zwei wo er nun allerdings alleine
ist denn samira ist schon lange nicht
mehr da sie ist zurück in der schweiz
ich habe immer dafür alles aber ich je
gefragt jede meinung was sie dankt
jetzt macht der hustende sie ist nicht
immer ich kann nicht immer fragen was
sie dann findet sie gut und ich mache
das gern ich wollte dass mit ihr
kommunizieren
sie fanden das auch gut
und jetzt ist sie nicht da ich vermisse
sie jeden tag jeden moment ist natürlich
schwieriger moment sie
ja
sehr schwierig es war so hart
wir sind eigentlich ganz thema
überall mir mit den tests zusammen kann
einkaufen
klägerin jungen besuchen
alles wenn wir zusammen gemacht und
jetzt plötzlich war sie niemals
ja immer noch komisch alleine darf zu
fahren sie hat mich immer schon
festgehalten
so ist es
geblieben sind ihm ihre
liebesbotschaften immerhin
[Musik]
wer treffen samira wieder in flüelen
sie arbeitet in einer papeterie instanz
und sie wohnte an einem neuen ort sie
ist bei ihrer mutter eingezogen
sonst scheint alles beim alten zu sein
jedenfalls fast alles
einiges wirft fragen auf
nun liest die fleissig bücher um sich
auf die ankunft ihres ersten kindes
vorzubereiten eines kindes von dem sie
ehrlich gesagt schon in der karibik
wusste das süße geheimnis aber nur mit
ihrer mutter und carlos teilte
das ist nur eine ganz
lange und er hat sich mit freude hat man
mich ruft luft und kunden
gewinnen und ich würde es ganz witzig
und überraschend einfach wirklich hat
sehr freuen
ganz gut
danke
aber
es geht das ganz schlimm ist und
weniger frauen aber mit mama wenn meine
familie mich komisch
es gibt schon moment wo oder einfach
ingenieur geprüft ich jetzt gerade aber
will ich morgen bis zum teil
so situationen garten wo
[Musik]
umso enger ist nun die beziehung zu
ihrer mutter angela mit der sie kataloge
für baby accessoires studiert nach ihrer
rückkehr sei schnell klar gewesen dass
sie die wohnung die sie mit carlos
bewohnt hatte aufgeben wollte
ich habe doch
wie einsamkeit vor
und darum habe ich das allemal
doch seit
ich muss jetzt
von epic zero mx hat dass ich zu ihrer
der froh und wähler das
liebesglück jetzt als ich das erlebe
dass sie wieder da ist und so gut
miteinander
es ist einfach schön
offen ist indes was dieses baby nun für
samira auswanderungs pläne bedeutet geht
sie oder bleibt sie
[Musik]
will ich einen erfahrung machte die
dominikanische mit dem frauenarzt in
also einfach das ganze gesundheitssystem
habe ich nicht
kennengelernt und
mir das einfach das ganze längst gemacht
und
fühle mich wohl bei der schweiz es
drängt sich hat es gefahren und auch
sicherlich
größer ist dass sie weiß es wirklich
alles gut kommt
[Musik]
carlos baut weiter jeden tag am haus in
dem er eigentlich mit samira leben
wollte
der traum vom gemeinsamen glück in der
karibik ist nun allerdings geplatzt
[Musik]
ja es ist
ein job zuerst also sage ich so sexy
wird mich begleiten
um zukunft dazu machen und ich habe das
eriz genommen und darum habe ich so viel
gemacht ich habe gesagt ich muss heim
für uns zu hause
und ich hatte so ernst genommen dass er
das recht das ihr gefällt dass sie da
bekommen hat dass sie kann sarah ja ich
mir handys jene zu hause mir hat alles
mit einbrüchen
rudig sie am anfang
ja jetzt ich
hab ja gut ich habe ich auch erwartet
dass sie
völlig zurück guard und aber vielleicht
wieder kommt man nicht sogar wieder
kommt wie sie sagt ja ich bleibe
aber ich glaube ich glaube nicht dass
sie wiederkommt zum lieber denke sie
kommen nun zum ferien machen ist für
mich okay
[Musik]
es hätte der anfang eines neuen lebens
in der alten heimat werden sollen da
führen carlos alles aufgegeben in der
schweiz
[Musik]
wenn sie nicht kann da sieht man muss
sich in der schweiz kommt
und ich hätte mir sogar lieber lecker ob
sich soll oder nicht also ich sage
wenn sie nicht schwanger wäre hätte ich
mir nach der überleitung sich soll
aber jetzt sind wir eine familie und ich
komme sehr gerne zurück aber der leiter
bliebe das würdigt die franco scheute
schweiz mit dem kind und udo
dass ich ganz klar
[Musik]
wenn er mit dem schicksal hadert dann
zieht es carlos zum grab seines vaters
dorthin wo 4a biccari seine letzte ruhe
gefunden hat
[Musik]
zu seinem vater dem schnapsbrenner aus
rotkreuz der in der karibik all sein
geld verloren und dafür die liebe
gefunden hat
[Musik]
zu dem mann aus der schweiz den hier
alle mochten
und der doch vielen irgendwie ein rätsel
blieb das fing schon bei seinem
nachnamen an
den vergaser
hierüber darum muss sich immer wieder
mit den vielen
struktur
[Musik]
ich danke dass labbadia bis an das
kabinett wollte
und damit löst er sich hätte er es zum
a8 mit dem
zuzug ist das bei dir ich liebe die
rolle ja
zu viel licht viel lichtershow ja
ich einfach keine angst
ich nehme die sache so wie es kommt und
ich mache einfach das beste
was ich
weiß ich kann glücklich sie egal
das ist
[Musik]
die geschichte der familie feierabend
ist noch lange nicht zu ende erzählt
denn ihre suche nach dem glück geht
weiter
irgendwo zwischen hier und dort
[Musik]
meine freundin lucy ich hoffe dass sie
bald wieder zu und es wurde
[Musik]
ihnen präsentiert von fleurop punkt ch